c'est ça aussi le message d'aujourd'hui
le sais que je vais bien faut pas que
les gens s'inquiètent le message est
fort après dix jours de silence marie
josée savard se remet tranquillement de
sa défaite crève coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déclarée gagnante 28 minutes après
l'ouverture des premières boîtes de
scrutin le 7 novembre elle perdra deux
heures plus tard par un peu plus de 800
votes c'est clair que ce soir là au
moment où tout a basculé
j'ai l'impression qu'on m'avait pris le
coeur commun l'avait mis sur la table
mais un coup de feu puis avec un peu de
recul je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup plus
de positif
marie josée savard ne changerait rien
aux dernières semaines les fier de sa
campagne et les fier de son équipe elle
choisi de regarder devant encore là ça
ne donnerait rien de venir acheter
tellement proches oui mais ça veut dire
justement car on a fait une bonne
campagne qui nous était bonne puisque
les gens nous faisait confiance donc
c'est vraiment comme ça que j'ai le goût
de
de continuer à jouer dur et à me
reconstruire elle reconnaît qu'elle a
souvent dû défendre le bilan du maire la
bombe durant les 52 jours de campagne le
tramway et le patrimoine ont ponctué les
attaques de ses adversaires elle était
consciente du défi après un règne de 14
ans est-ce que ça a été plus lourd que
je pensais pas nécessairement du même
coup monsieur là bon tout le monde
pensait qu'elle est hyper présent
pendant la campagne finalement il ya
vraiment été très en deçà et que c'est
sûr que ça m'a amené un poids
supplémentaire parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas nécessairement là pour défendre le
bilan puisqu'ils étaient plus il était
plus dans la vie publique mais en même
temps il ya tenu sa promesse donc elle
se donne maintenant du temps pour
réinventer la suite propriétaire d'un
café elle ne renonce pas aux services
publics mais il n'a pas d'appétit pour
la politique à court terme ni tellement
proximité avec les gens on peut pas
vraiment faire une différence
donc je me ferme pas de porte pour
l'instant mais c'est sûr que je mettrais
pas ma face sur un poteau bientôt
si louise boisvert radio canada québec